hey guys my name is Jess we're about a
month out from eighth grade and already
the game reveals and trailers are
rolling in be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss any but for now here's what's
going on
[Music]
first up Bandai Namco have released a
new trailer for the upcoming vampire RPG
code vein and still looking stylish and
gory the trailer shows off some lovely
world environments the art style and a
glimpse of the combat which is putting
out serious Dark Souls vibes the trailer
also delivers a quick look at how the
companion mechanic will work players can
select a companion from the game world
of Vayne
but you'll need to choose a companion
who works well with your style of play
so there's a bit more nuance to it in
code vein you play as a revenant in the
future world with nasties to vanquish
and Blood veils to exploit to boost your
abilities the game is scheduled to
launch in 2018 for consoles if you
didn't manage to grab that ironclad tour
beyond skin where you can totally see
his left hand not to worry as Blizzard
have extended over watch's uprising a
bit after an accidental slip-up that
caused the event to end earlier than
originally planned lizard are making it
up by extending the event until 5:00
p.m. on May 2 so yeah you have like an
hour if you're watching this as soon as
it goes up go I'm not going to keep you
lizard posted a message on Twitter
saying the event ended early G - a
mistake and they were in the process of
renaming uprising loot boxes and the
King's row uprising brawl this might be
something Blizzard needs to address as
the Halloween event also ended earlier
than it should have upsetting a lot of
people following a leaked by Amazon
earlier today Darksiders 3 has been
officially announced this time you'll be
playing as a mage named fury on a quest
to destroy the seven deadly sins and
their servants according to the Amazon
listing you'll be able to explore an
open-ended living freeform
game world in which fury moves back and
forth between environments to uncover
secrets while advancing the story
darkside is 3 is in development at
gunfire games which is made up of many
Vigil gains employees who worked on the
original two games again according to
Amazon of the game will run you 60 bucks
and is coming to ps4 Xbox one and PC on
December 31 2018 although that could
very well be a placeholder date that's
everything I've got for you today do let
me know down in that comment section
what you thought about today's stories
and I will be back with more news
tomorrow